Good morning, I'm Josh Welsh, President of
Film Independent. Welcome to the 2022 Spirit
Awards Emerging Filmmakers Awards reveal.
Joining me today are a three very talented
previous Spirit Award grant winners: Ekwa Msangi,
Elegance Bratton and Gerry Kim. Today we will
be announcing the nominees and winners of three
emerging filmmaker awards, the Someone To Watch,
Producers and Truer Than Fiction awards, each
chosen for their unique vision and commitment
to the craft. I am thrilled to say that all three
award winners will receive a twenty five thousand
dollar unrestricted cash grant. Now, on with
the announcements... Hello I'm Ekwa Msangi,
the recipient of the 2021 Someone To Watch award
for my film Farewell Amour. I remember distinctly
winning this award last year sitting in my kitchen
and feeling so overwhelmed and surprised that
I had actually been seen and heard in what seemed
like a vacuous pit in the year of 2020/2021
with covid and being on zoom and just not
knowing if anyone had even seen or heard
the work that me and my team did together. So it
was such an honor and a pleasure and I hope that
it is the same for this year's winner and leads
you along a wonderful path as it did for myself
and my team. I'm delighted to be announcing the
2022 Someone to Watch award. This is an award that
honors a talented filmmaker of singular vision
who has not yet received appropriate recognition.
The finalists for this year are
Alex Camilleri, director of Luzzu,
Gillian Wallace Horvat director of
I Blame Society, Michael Sarnoski
director of Pig All three nominees for the Someone
to Watch award built distinctive worlds and filled
them with thoughtfully crafted characters and
stories. The winner of this year's award embraced
the rituals of a traditional way of life as it's
threatened by the bureaucracies of the future.
This director brilliantly captures the complexity
that exists in a seemingly simple world channeling
authenticity at every level the summon to watch
award goes to Alex Camilleri director of Luzzu.
Congratulations Alex! Hey everyone I'm Gerry
Kim the recipient of the 2021 Producers Award.
It was an incredible honor to have received this
award last year since so many of its previous
winners went to producers I deeply deeply admire
and respect. I remember when it was announced last
year, I was sitting in my car on a scout and
in complete shock that I had won and more so
I was incredibly happy to have been representing
all the filmmakers that I previously worked with
in the past and I was excited to share this
award with them. The Producers award honors
emerging producers who despite highly limited
resources demonstrate the creativity tenacity and
vision required to produce quality independent
films. The finalists are: Brad Becker-Parton,
Pin-Chun Liu, and Lizzie Shapiro The Producers
Award committee tasks themselves with selecting
three producers who are making high quality
work oftentimes with very limited means
and are creating and providing opportunities for
emerging filmmakers from disparate backgrounds.
The committee has chosen to honor a producer who
is well respected by peers is already carving a
path that reflects a commitment to films that
in their own words bring joy and ask complex
questions. This year's producer's award goes
to Lizzie Shapiro. Congratulations, Lizzy!
Is that your life? Yeah yes. That's my life.
Well, lucky you. Hi I'm Elegance Bratton,
the recipient of the 2021 Truer Than
Fiction award for my documentary Pier Kids
and first of all I want to say thank you
again the film independent and wonderful
sponsors who made this possible. The past year
has been incredible our movie appeared on POV,
we're currently nominated for a GLAAD award
and the Truer Than Fiction award has just
made it possible for me to live my life as an
artist while also being passionate about what I
believe in. The Truer Than Fiction award honors
an emerging director of nonfiction features
who work has not yet received appropriate
recognition. This year's finalists are:
Jessica Beshir director of Faya Dayi, Angelo
Madsen Minax director of North by Current,
and Debbie Lum director of Try
Harder! Even though each are still
in the beginning stages of their careers, the
three nominees for the truth of fiction award
helm documentaries that exemplify the range of
what's possible within nonfiction storytelling
offering deep insight to lives and situations with
clearly honed perspectives. The winner of this
year's award crafted a memorably contemplative
intimate and immersive look at the ritual and
community at the complex intersection of religious
meditation in a lucrative national windfall.
Without further adieu, the Truer Than Fiction
award goes to Jessica Beshir for Faya Deyi.
Congratulations Jessica! Enjoy it! Buy me a
drink when we see each other in real life!
And there you have it. I encourage you
to check out the work of our emerging
filmmaker award nominees and winners
and extend another thank you to Ekwa,
Elegence and Gerry for joining us for today's
announcement. A special thanks to all those
supporters of the 2022 Film Independent Spirit
Awards, including our Premier sponsor IFC,
our official spirit Bulleit Frontier Whiskey
and Seedlip, our official water Fiji Water and
our official beer Stella Artois. Don't forget
to watch the Spirit Awards on Sunday, March 6th
live on IFC at 5 pm Eastern. For more information
go to spiritawards.com. Congratulations to all the
emerging filmmaker award winners and nominees of
the 2022 Film Independent Spirit Awards. Cheers!
you